tesla fabrik in deutschland der
amerikanische elektro autobauer will ein
werk in brandenburg bauen tausende
arbeitsplätze sollen entstehen
das gab es noch nie im bundestag der
rechtsausschuss wählt seinen
vorsitzenden ab stefan brandner von der
afg werden hass und hetze vorgeworfen
und hochwasser bedroht venedig die
lagunenstadt kämpft mit den schlimmsten
überflutungen seit mehr als 50 jahren
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den sport fun
junior familie
es ist ein zufall berlin und brandenburg
elon musk milliardär und pionier im
geschäft mit elektroautos hat
angekündigt in brandenburg die erste
tesla produktion in europa anzusiedeln
es winken rund 7000 neue arbeitsplätze
wirtschaftsminister altmaier spricht von
einem meilenstein für den ausbau der
elektromobilität
tesla ist zwar vergleichsweise klein
2018 baute das kalifornische unternehmen
fast 250.000 elektroautos aber die firma
wächst enorm gilt als kultmarke und ist
dem deutschen autoriesen in sachen
elektromobilität um jahre voraus auch
weil sie eben nicht nur autos produziert
sondern auch batterien und ladesäulen
warum künftig in berlin und brandenburg
bitten erwarten hat die details in ganz
europa hatten sich standort um das neue
werk beworben bei einer preisverleihung
in berlin verkündete tesla-chef die
entscheidung und nennt gründe nur so
jeder weiß dass die deutsche
ingenieurskunst hervorragend ist und das
ist einer der gründe warum wie die giga
fabrik in deutschland bauen
zusätzlich siedeln wir eine entwicklungs
und designzentrum in berlin an
berlin mit seinem hit modernen image das
passt zur premium marke tesla grünheide
punkte mit der nähe zur hauptstadt und
dem flughafen ber aber auch mit großen
verfügbaren industrieflächen für tesla
wird es subventionen im rahmen des eu
rechtes geben aber für den autobauer war
ein entscheidendes kriterium dass es in
brandenburg besonders viel windkraft
gibt und deswegen bin ich fest davon
überzeugt dass wir mit diesen
investitionen auch zeigen können dass
erneuerbare energien nicht nur gut sind
fürs klima sondern auch gut für die
wirtschaft gut für arbeitsplätze
bisher hat tesla hoch automatisierte
fabriken in amerika und china
in brandenburg sollen in zukunft
batterien antriebe und ein neues scw
kompaktmodell gebaut werden für die
strukturschwache region um grünheider
ein großer schritt ja ich finds gut ich
denke das ist für die entwicklung vor
ort wirklich nur von vorteil sein kann
ja überragend für brandenburg also ich
komme aus erkner ist direkt daneben ort
also ich war überrascht positiv
überrascht die deutschen autohersteller
neben die kampfansage an
wir freuen uns auch über den wettbewerb
den die deutsche automobilindustrie hat
immer gezeigt dass sie in intensiven
wettbewerb innovativ ist starkes und
weiter wächst
schwierigkeiten bei der produktion und
zu ambitionierte wachstumspläne machten
tesla in der vergangenheit immer wieder
probleme
noch ist der bau der giga fabrik eine
ankündigung umweltfreundlich unterwegs
sind elektroautos nur wenn sie auch
klimafreundlich produzierten strom
tanken eine schlüsseltechnologie dafür
ist eben die windkraft doch die steckt
in deutschland nach jahren des booms in
der krise und das klima paket der
bundesregierung könnte die windkraft
entgegen allen guten absichten noch
weiter ausbremsen christoph distel
berichtet keine abgase gut fürs klima
schont dem planeten das hinten fast alle
gut außer vor der eigenen haustür
daher will die regierung jetzt den
deutschen die angst vom windrad nehmen
per gesetz umso mehr räder mehr
klimaschutz zu schaffen herauskommen
könnte aber sogar das gegenteil
befürchtet die branche mit denen
rahmenbedingungen die derzeit gesetz
sind zu geringe flächen zu wenig
baugenehmigung zu große abstände sorgt
die bundesregierung dafür dass wir
dieses potenzial nicht nutzen
dass die industrie wie bereits vor
sieben jahren die photovoltaik in andere
länder ab siedelt das gesetz legt
nämlich ein mindestabstand fest 1000
meter bis zur nächsten siedlung für
jedes neue windrad wobei siedlung heißt
alles ab fünf gebäude schon jetzt ist
die vorgesehene fläche für zusätzliche
räder knapp mit der 1000 meter regel
würde sie noch mal um etwa 40 prozent
schrumpfen und sogar das umweltbundesamt
warnt so ist der geplante ausbau beim
ökostrom nicht zu schaffen
die folge der abseitsregelung wäre das
das 65
20 30 auf den flächen nicht erreichbar
wäre das heißt wir bräuchten neue
flächenausweisungen um genug raum für
die windenergie zu schaffen dabei wird
schon länger kaum noch gebaut
genehmigungsverfahren ziehen sich hin
bürger stellen sich quer
und jetzt obendrauf noch der 1000 meter
abstand ob er gelten wird oder nicht
laut gesetz bekommen die bundesländer
das letzte wort und mindestens einem
geht das ganze schon jetzt zu weit
innerhalb der niedersächsischen
landesregierung sind für uns einig dass
wir diese abstandsregelung für unser
land nicht für richtig halten
im schlimmsten fall droht der
angeschlagene wind branche nicht nur
noch mehr planungsunsicherheit sie
könnte sogar einzelne anlagen verlieren
dann nämlich wenn altersschwache räder
nicht durch neue ersetzt werden dürfen
weil sie im 1000 meter radius liegen
das gab es noch nie in 70 jahren
bundestag zum ersten mal hat ein
ausschuss seinen vorsitzenden abgewählt
den fdp abgeordneten stefan brandner
wegen wiederholter entgleisungen sei der
53 jährige aus thüringen an der spitze
des rechtsausschusses nicht mehr haltbar
da waren sich die mitglieder aller
fraktionen außer seiner eigenen einig
aus berlin russlands showdown im
rechtsausschuss des bundestages selten
war das interesse so groß noch nie wurde
ein vorsitzender abgewählt doch stefan
brandner von der afg hat nach
überzeugung aller anderen parteien
überzogen
die afg dagegen nutzt den rauswurf als
bühne stellt sich als opfer dar kein
schuldbewusstsein keine reue
im gegenteil wir gehen mit erhobenem
haupt hier raus das ist keine niederlage
das einfach eine art parteienkoalition
die sie immer gegen die afg stattfindet
egal was wir machen die wollten mich
weghaben
die wollen der fdf de vor schienbein
treten bis auf die afc einstimmig das
urteil aller fraktionen brand nass
provokationen und grenzüberschreitungen
seien nicht mehr tragbar hat mit
unsäglichen tweets gegen minderheiten
gehetzt er hat die wichtigen gespräche
nach dem anschlag in halle die wir
politiker mit religionsgemeinschaften
geführt haben als herumlungern
verächtlich
gemacht brandner selbst nennt sich einen
pückler mehrfach hat er auf twitter mit
meldungen für ärger gesorgt doch dieser
retreat brachte das fass zum überlaufen
warum lungern politiker mit kerzen in
moscheen und synagogen rum wir fühlen
uns von stefan brandner nicht
repräsentiert und er sollte uns auch
nicht länger repräsentieren
insofern ist die abberufung von den
brandner ein klares signal gegen hetze
und hass ein einmaliger vorgang die idee
hatten das recht einen neuen
vorsitzenden zu benennen
darüber will sie in der fraktion
demnächst diskutieren
drei wichtige entscheidungen heute im
kabinett die erste betrifft grundschüler
nach dem rechtsanspruch auf den
kita-platz kommt nun auch der
rechtsanspruch auf einen ganztagsplatz
in der grundschule los gehen soll es
außerdem brachte die bundesregierung
zwei neue verbote gegen gaffer und
voyeure auf den weg da wird sauer wenn
sensationslust voran stand geht gaffer
machten sich bislang nur strafbar wenn
sie rettungskräfte behinderten oder
verletzte besonders entwürdigend
fotografierten aufnahmen von toten
blieben bislang straffrei
deswegen es ist wichtig dass dieses
signal kommt es handelt sich hier um
tote menschen und man könnte auch sagen
so etwas macht man nicht aber das reicht
nicht und deswegen ist es erforderlich
dass diese strafrechtliche lücke
geschlossen wird dieses signal soll auch
einer form modernen spanner teams
einhalt gebieten
heimliches fotografieren und filmen
unter den rock von frauen ein eingriff
in die intimsphäre demütigend verletzend
hanna seidel war 16 als sie auf einem
festival opfer wurde
ich habe mich unfassbar schutzlos und
benutzt gefühlt also man fragt sich dann
was macht dieser mann mit den aufnahmen
das sogenannte ups körting soll zur
straftat werden das hat das kabinett
beschlossen
damit wird endlich eine strafbarkeit
lücke geschlossen denn bislang gab es
schlicht keinen straftatbestand er es
verboten hat dass man in deutschland auf
offener straße oder im park einer frau
unter den rock filmt damit es eine
strafbare sexuelle belästigung gewesen
wäre hätte die frau dabei körperlich
berührt werden müssen
das war in der regel nicht der fall und
damit eine strafbare beleidigung gewesen
wäre die frau das ganz mitbekommen
müssen das war auch in der regel nicht
der fall
und so blieb die täter oft unbestraft
anna seidel startete eine petition die
mehr als 100.000 menschen
unterzeichneten der kabinettsbeschluss
heute ist auch ihr erfolg
ups körting und aufnahmen von
unfalltoten sind wohl bald straftaten
dann drohen freiheitsstrafen bis zu zwei
jahren nach langem hin und her hat sich
die große koalition ja auf den
kompromiss zur grundrente geeinigt die
präsidentin der deutschen
rentenversicherung rosbach zweifelt
allerdings ob das so schnell wie geplant
überhaupt zu schaffen es bis zum ersten
januar übernächsten jahres millionen
laufender renten müssten geprüft und
auch der datenaustausch zwischen
finanzbehörden und rentenkassen
organisiert werden unangenehme tag für
us-präsident seit drei stunden befragt
der geheimdienstausschuss erstmals
öffentlich zeugen zur ukraine affäre
live im amerikanischen fernsehen
im kern geht es darum hatte den
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky in
einem telefongespräch dazu gedrängt
gegen seinen möglichen demokratischen
herausforderer joe biden und dessen so
rum zu ermitteln gleichzeitig hier das
weiße haus militär halfen an die ukraine
zurück für die demokraten ein klarer
fall von amtsmissbrauch aus washington m
at wissen
william taylor kann eine geschichte
erzählen die donald trump so gar nicht
gefallen wird der us botschafter in der
ukraine hat penibel in notizbüchern
seine erfahrungen in diesem sommer
festgehalten
der medienrummel und der tiefe graben
zwischen demokraten und republikanern
gefährden die ernsthaftigkeit des
verfahrens aber wer hier die unwahrheit
spricht macht sich dass mein als
schuldig es geht um viel
wenn der präsident einen verbündeten
erpressen und bestechen wollte
ermittlungen zu gunsten seiner
wiederwahl durchzuführen indem er ein
treffen im weißen haus oder hunderte von
millionen dollar militärhilfe verweigert
müssen wir das einfach hinnehmen
regierungsmitarbeiter sind beauftragt
die politik des gewählten präsidenten
umzusetzen einige
des staatsdienstes haben entschieden
dass nicht der präsident sondern sie das
sagen haben
gemeint sind beamte wie taylor der sich
aber nicht einschüchtern lässt
er sagte mir dass präsident trump von
seelands die eine öffentliche
verpflichtung wollte die ermittlungen an
zuordnet das so taylor habe ihm der
amerikanische botschafter bei der eu
unter berufung auf donald trump genauso
gesagt dass der präsident mehr daran
liegt als an der ukraine
ja klar als bild taylor könnte ein zeuge
kaum sein der us präsident habe seine
persönlichen interessen über die des
landes gestellt das könnte sich wie ein
roter faden durch die anhörungen ziehen
und donald trumps zustimmung im land
massiv beschädigen
aber nur wenn mindestens 20 republikaner
am ende auch im senat mit für eine
amtsenthebung stimmen würde trump
abgelöst und das erscheint derzeit noch
unmöglich zurück nach deutschland im
raum ulm soll eine 14 jährige von
mehreren jungen männern und jugendlichen
vergewaltigt worden sein
drei beschuldigte sitzen in
untersuchungshaft das mädchen war in der
halloween-nacht offenbar mit fünf
asylbewerbern unterwegs im wohnhaus
eines der verdächtigen sei sie
vergewaltigt worden sagte sie der
polizei
die niederländische regierung macht das
was in deutschland für viele wohl
unvorstellbar wäre um den ausstoß von
stickoxiden zu senken führt sie
tempolimit 100 auf allen autobahnen 1
zumindest tagsüber ausnahmen soll es
nachts geben der deutsche bundestag
hatte ein tempolimit 130 erst vor
wenigen wochen abgelehnt
die menschen in venedig kämpfen mit
einem außergewöhnlichen hochwasser große
teile des unesco-welterbes sind
überflutet starker wind und dauerregen
ließen das wasser so hoch steigen wie
seit 50 jahren nicht mehr
venedigs bürgermeister spricht von
apokalyptischen zerstörungen und macht
den klimawandel dafür verantwortlich
annette hilsenbeck
80 prozent der stadt unter wasser
gondeln und schiffe fortgerissen
solche fluten haben selbst viele
venezianer noch nicht erlebt und schon
jetzt ist klar dieses mal hat das acqua
alta das jährliche hochwasser große
schäden angerichtet
die besucher der stadt spazieren die
holzstege entlang fasziniert von den
fluten die einwohner sehen die nicht an
unser haus zum beispiel ist ebenerdig
und jedes mal wenn es so ein hochwasser
gibt steht es unter wasser dieses
phänomen macht der stadt große probleme
um kurz vor mitternacht war das wasser
auf 187 zentimeter über dem normalen
meeresspiegel gestiegen
angetrieben durch heftigen südwind der
das wasser in die kanäle drückte hotels
geschäfte restaurants überall dringt das
wasser ein überwindet sämtliche
schutzbarrieren die schäden sollen
hunderte millionen betragen so der
bürgermeister es sind nicht nur die
denkmäler hier die schaden nehmen auch
die venezianer die ihr hier seht die mit
dem wasser kämpfen die versuchen
durchzuhalten
der markusplatz steht tief unter wasser
auch der dom überflutet das wasser drang
in die basilika ein floss in die krypta
durch solche extrem hochwasser und ihre
starke strömung befürchten experten für
das bauwerk und seine statik probleme
seit jahren ist geplant dass die
lagunenstadt durch eine flugsperre vor
der küste geschützt wird doch das
projekt stoppt so bleibt venedig
weiterhin den fluten des acqua alta
ausgeliefert wasser das bräuchten die
australier dringend dort hat es
mancherorts seit drei jahren nicht
geregnet die dürre ist ein grund für die
buschfeuer dort im bundesstaat
queensland ordneten mehrere gemeinden
evakuierungen an
seit tagen wüten in australien über 100
brände die feuerwehr spricht von einer
katastrophalen lage ein lösch
hubschrauber stürzte ab der pilot wurde
leicht verletzt
jetzt zu dir norbert mit erfreulichem
von der para wm der leichtathleten in
dubai genau die sechste goldmedaille für
das deutsche team
markus rehm hat sie geholt im weitsprung
ein souveräner sieg des 31 jährigen
der mann ist ja sowieso eine klasse für
sich schon seit fünfter wm titel im
weitsprung
zum greifen nahe wie der mond über den
persischen golf ist für markus rehm die
goldmedaille bereits nach seinem ersten
gültigen sprung auf knapp acht meter der
orthopädie techniker aus leverkusen
steigert sich hier im fünften versuch
noch auf acht meter 17
in der klasse der unterschenkel
amputierten ein vorsprung von fast einem
meter vor der konkurrenz bei starkem
gegenwind
unter den bedingungen sind 817 wirklich
wirklich in ordnung
ich glaube wer wen anderen gestanden da
war deutlich mehr gegangen aber ich bin
happy der fünfte wm titel in folge und
das sind als ergebnis rehms
vereinskamerad felix streng verliert
dagegen bronze im letzten sprung um
lediglich einen zentimeter
überlegener weltmeister aber markus rehm
die erwartet harte strafe des
dfb-sportgerichts gegen david abraham
sieben wochen sperre der kapitän von
eintracht frankfurt war am sonntag nach
einer tätlichkeit gegen freiburgs
trainer streich vom platz geflogen
frankfurt hat einspruch gegen das urteil
eingelegt
bundestrainer joachim löw bereitet sein
team auf die em qualifikationsspiele
gegen weißrussland am samstag und
nordirland am dienstag vor probleme gibt
es vor allem in der abwehr beim training
mit 21 spielern fehlte verteidiger
niklas stark der modell ein
aufbautraining absolvierte nach
nasenbeinbruch und op ist ein einsatz
noch nicht absehbar kürzer treten
mussten heute auch die leicht
angeschlagenen serdar und tat für die
zwei spiele
die beiden nicht ausverkauft sind gibt
es eine passgenaue ausrichtung dass wir
natürlich jetzt die qualifikation
klarmachen können auch im ersten spiel
das ist natürlich das klare ziel aber
darüber hinaus natürlich auch ein gutes
spiel zu machen noch offen ob torwart
neuer in beiden spielen zum einsatz
kommt oder ob konkurrenz testen
eine chance erhält das war zu mir vielen
dank gehört jetzt noch das lotto die
gewinnzahlen lauten 17 18 20 29 38 44
und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
unser metrologie osten terry hat mir
aufgetragen ich soll sie unbedingt
warnen in der nacht wird ist teilweise
glatt auf den straßen mehr dazu gleich
beim wetter marietta slomka freut sich
auf sie im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn danke für ihr interesse haben sie
noch einen unbeschwerten abend und bis
morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schön kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter vorübergehend ruhiger wird es
in deutschland mit einem zwischenhoch ja
aber schauen sie mal richtung
vereinigtes königreich dort rauscht ein
tief weiter nach süden richtung spanien
und sorgt hier für unwetter genauso wie
in den nächsten tagen dann neue tief
sich im mittelmeerraum dann bilden
werden und ebenfalls für unwetter sorgen
werden
schauen wir nach deutschland über der
mitte gibt es zunächst einmal regen und
schnee anfangs der nacht und dann klart
es auf und es wird spiegel die lage auf
den straßen nach norden in richtung
schleswig holstein gibt es auch etwas
regen und schnee ansonsten klart es im
süden auf und dann gehen die
temperaturen zurück bis auf minus zehn
grad über schneeflächen ganz im westen
sind es plus vier grad
morgen gibt es im westen wieder viele
wolken ansonsten im osten viel
sonnenschein im süden muss erst der
nebel verschwinden und dann zeigt sich
auch hier die sonne bei temperaturen
zwischen 3 grad am alpenrand und 9 grad
nach osten hin den nächsten tage am
freitag kommt im süden regen und schnee
auf nach norden gibt es viele wolken
aber ist es insgesamt trocken an der
nordsee wird es stürmisch 3 bis 14 grad
und am samstag vor allem im nordwesten
viel regen bei 3 bis 10 grad
ein schöner abend